What the heck is this?
Where did the idiot who picked a fight with me come from? Wow,
but I never expected he
would actually get caught. Please hit me, why do I
have to hit you? There
's a reason why you're being hit.  It's your body.I don't know
why I hit you.When I was in high school,
under the cherry blossom trees, you
said
you liked me.I did
n't mean it as a friend.  I guess you were
aware of my confession. It
seems like you knew how I felt. You
knew I was trying to be feminine for you, but you were
ignoring me.  As a woman, I didn't
realize that.
[Applause] I
hit you. I don't have the
right to hit you, but I
know how painful it feels to want to run away.
[Music]
Jun was also scared, but
now he's
looking straight at me without running away.  Are you
running away now? Wait,
your feelings may have changed already,
but I still love you.